if you're in a service business this
video's for you, so just right now I went to
I'm in Boston right now by the way this place is hot it's happening, if you're from Boston there's something special
about people in Boston there's something real special about people in Boston. We just went to
Fenway Park watched the game my first time
in Fenway Park had a blast, here for some
reasons with some other business people
but anyways. Look service very basic I
was literally about to go down to a
restaurant down there you don't see it's
called Island Creek Oyster Bar. I'll put the
Yelp account so you can see it's
four-and-a-half star, 1900 reviews I was
so looking forward to going to that
place
this is why service is so critical when
I hire a front desk clerk
I can't ever be a front desk clerk, I
can't ever be a hostess, I can't ever be
the first
first contact with customer because I'm
not built to be a front desk clerk, I'm
not built to be a hostess. My personality
is probably not going to be the best
hostess. I could be a behind-the-scenes or I
could be a waiter but maybe not a
hostess right and again this is
service.
Why? Because you gotta pick the most
approachable likeable people that have a
pleasant smile and their tolerance is
just lower and we just want to Island
Creek Oyster Bar and my Gosh! I mean she's in
front of me on the phones for three minutes okay
not once looks at us, nothing and
three minutes later, she says how many in the party? I said three, she grabs three menus and starts walking not saying please follow me
I'll get you a table. I get to the table, she
still hasn't spoken to me and then we come
over here we're at Eastern
Standard, right there, behind me. okay
we've never been here before
it's got nice reviews.
Front desk hostess, sweet, gentle, kind,
patient, "please let me get you a nicer
table if you can wait five minutes i
will get your nicer table to have privacy.
I understand it's loud, let me see if I
can get this place for you. I can sit you
down right now about the bar but it's
not the best table i don't recommend it
it's up to you
either way you're going to get great
service but if you go on the side I'll
get you the best table, if you can wait
five more minutes" and we said ok sure.
That's service. So I tell you this because
if you're watching this, be extremely
listen,  I have at an early part of my career,
I was not umm, very meticulous about this
area. I didn't pay attention to it, until I
realized how important of a roll the
first contact plays when somebody speaks
to them and I had somebody who was with
me her name is Alexis till today she's
been with me she's gone from you know
initially being an extremely part-time
front desk person to now I mean you know
she's doing extremely well for herself
with her job and I'm not talking
extremely well-liked making three four
five thousand dollars you doing very
well for herself and she started as a
front desk you know why? Because she made
everybody feel good,
everybody feel good. I don't care if
you're running a massive business or if
you're running a small business, if
you're running whatever type of business
you're running. Just make sure whoever
that is the first person people touch is
as pleasant, approachable, nice, patient,
kind as they get us CEO's sometimes tend
to get a lot more credit than we need to
get because without the person at the
front, there is no contact with the CEO.
That Oyster restaurant Island Creek,
whatever it's called, just lost a four hundred dollar bill tonight. Tonight! It's not a
big deal they're not going to be hit by it
but there's a video being talked about
it just because the front desk hostess
didn't treat customers well they just
want service. I'm not going there because
you know you know just going to a
restaurant and she's going for service
gonna try the food I heard about it I'm
at the Fenway park I'm leaving the game
I'm here with 200 other business people
that do 20, 30, 40, 50 million dollars of
gross revenues or more per year or some even two, three billion a year we're here
strategizing and we want to go to a nice
restaurant.
So, again I don't want to do a long rant,
it's been four minutes and thirty-two seconds
I told myself it'd be less than five minutes.
Think about who you hire that your
customers, your market, whoever it is that
reaches out to find out about your
company, think about whoever touches you first, be extremely meticulous about who you hire
that handles that important job.
I'm out, I'm a go grab some food here.
Take care bye-bye.